[Musique]
mes chers concitoyens beaucoup d'entre
vous ne me connaissent certainement pas
moi de mon côté
la plupart d'entre eux ou sont des
inconnus pour moi et pourtant
journellement eux je partage vos soucis
et vos peines vos espoirs aussi
n'aurais-je été désignée comme candidat
à la présidence de la république
je serai en cet instant à ma mairie de
mulhouse en train de me pencher sur les
problèmes qui préoccupent journellement
mes administrés les enfants l'éducation
le travail le plein emploi le
développement économique et social la
sollicitude pour nos anciens tout ceci
ce sont des problèmes qui pour un
administrateur municipal
un de ceux qui à travers ce pays se
dévouent pour la cause publique sont le
lot de tous les jours mes amis
politiques ont demandé de dépasser ce
stade local c'est ainsi qu'aujourd'hui
je prends contact avec vous mes chers
concitoyens pour me présenter pour me
présenter afin que vous puissiez
comprendre au fil des enregistrements et
de mon passage à la télévision et à la
radio
mes positions vous puissiez comprendre
les réactions fils dans ses critères le
syndicat j'ai à l'âge de 14 ans commencé
mon apprentissage comme apprenti
imprimeur puis l'apprentissage terminé
j'ai été secrétaire de syndicats après
j'avoue avoir été amené à m'intéresser à
la collectivité publique que je
représente à l'heure actuelle je fus au
lendemain de la libération
conseiller municipal puis adjoint au
maire et depuis 1956 maire de la ville
de mulhouse
c'est vous dire que sur le plan de
l'administration municipale
j'ai eu à connaître de tout ce qui
touche à la personnalité humaine
j'ai eu à me pencher sur les problèmes
combien complexe de l'organisation d'une
collectivité comme la nôtre l'âge exact
qui m'ont emmené d'ailleurs à dire oui à
l'appel de mes amis politiques
lorsqu'ils m'ont demandé de représenter
dans cette campagne électorale le
courant réformateur
pourquoi moi et pas d'autres bien mes
chers concitoyens pour la simple raison
c'est qu'avec mes amis politiques je
m'étais battu au sein du mouvement
réformateur
enfin que celui ci soit présent dans
cette bataille électorale dont dépend en
grande partie de l'avenir de ce pays
j'avais en 1973 en entreprenant la
croisette avec mes amis politiques
plaider le dossier de cette forces
nouvelles qui devait se placer entre le
pouvoir actuel et la collusion
socialo-communiste de manière à éviter
l'affrontement à un certain moment nous
avions plein et le mouvement réformateur
et nous avons il faut bien dire une demi
victoire ou un demi-échec 3 millions 300
mille électrise électeurs se sont
prononcés contre la bipolarisation pour
le mouvement réformateur
ce demi-succès m'amener lorsque le
mouvement réformateur n'a pas désigné de
candidats m'amener à donner suite à la
demande de mes amis politiques du
mouvement démocrate socialiste de france
et c'est ainsi que aujourd'hui je me
présente à vous comme candidat démocrate
socialiste et candidat réformateur
quel va être mon programme
première question qu'on va me poser je
n'entrais pas je n'ai jamais eu de
programme électoral
j'ai toujours eu une position dans la
vie issus du sentiment que nous devons
les uns et les autres cherché à
rapprocher les hommes et les femmes de
bonne volonté qui veulent le progrès
social sans pour autant tomber dans le
travers d'une dictature au travers un
système qui est loin de nous garantir
nos libertés le programme je ne vais pas
l'inventer nous l'avons définies d'un
commun accord mes amis dans le cadre du
mouvement réformateur et moi même nous
l'avons signé il a signé par
jean-jacques servan-schreiber
il est signé par jean lecanu abelin
durafour et d'autre il a signé aussi par
moi même c'est pour ça que fidèle à cet
engagement sur ce programme du mouvement
réformateur
la base de notre mouvement au cours de
cette campagne
eh bien ce sera le programme
informateurs
le prochain programme réformateur qui a
il faut bien le dire et je le rappelle
était approuvée par quelque trois
millions trois cent mille électrisé
lecteur dans des conditions extrêmement
difficiles parti trop tard nous avions
une campagne à mener qui il faut bien le
dire a été quelque peu précipité
aujourd'hui je suis le candidat
réformateur et je veux que entre ceux
qui ont à supporter la responsabilité de
la politique passée et qui vous
promettent demain de faire une politique
nouvelle et peut se demander d'ailleurs
pourquoi ils ne l'ont pas appliqué
pendant les seize années pouvoir qu'ils
avaient je dirais presque de pouvoir
absolu
nous n'allons pas faire de promesses
vaines nous allons vous proposer des
solutions aux problèmes posés ces
solutions
nous allons les puiser dans le programme
réformateur puis au fur et à mesure de
notre rencontre nous allons tâcher de
vous dire quelles sont les solutions que
nous nous préconisons les solutions que
nous nous vous proposons et nous sommes
convaincus que les trois millions trois
cent mille deviendront demain 5 ou 6
millions et dames et messieurs mes chers
concitoyens
certains m'ont fait le reproche de ne
pas avoir de dimension nationale
tout le monde ne peut pas en avoir est
ce que je puis vous garantir dès ce
premier prix cette première prise de
contact
c'est que je garderai à travers la
campagne la dimension humaine que j'ai
toujours eue
[Musique]